hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well khan's
second formulation of the categorical
imperative
is always easier to understand when we
start applying it to a number of
different examples
and khan provides a number of these and
i discuss those in a different video
which which you can
you can watch i also go into you know
a bit more depth and detail about
precisely what goes on and what does all
this mean and
how this means and ends business in a
different video
in this one i actually want to consider
some examples that con doesn't bring up
but which
i've used in classes students have come
up with
at times and which i think could be very
helpful for helping you wrap your head
around
how you would actually apply this this
moral principle the the categorical
imperative
and this one is easier i think for the
average student to apply
and to understand than the first
formulation the first formulation
requires you to do a bit of imagining of
what would the world be like if
everybody did this and would there be
any logical contradictions and that gets
a little bit a little bit sticky
with this you can keep coming back to
the touchstone of
are you treating a person as if they
have dignity as if they
have a capacity to choose for themselves
are you respecting them or are you
treating them as what
calls a means as something to be used
as something which has value only in so
far
as it satisfies one of your own ends or
somebody else's
ends that's kind of a touchstone that
you can use but let's let's take a look
at certain examples
so before we do that let's review act in
such a way that you always treat
humanity whether in your own person or
in the person of another
never simply as a means but always is
the same at the same time as an end
so four important concepts there uh in
two pairs
you're supposed to treat humanity um
in your own person or in the person of
another
so you can't just get off the hook by
by saying i'm not hurting anybody else
i'm not affecting
anybody else so therefore whatever i do
is they okay kant says that's not the
case
because you have to be concerned with
duties that you actually have towards
yourself
and how you're treating humanity in
yourself
the other main set of concepts are that
the means and end
a means is something that you choose
or produce or pursue
or value because it leads to something
else that you
actually want more the the end and kant
says that we have merely subjective
ends which you know largely stem from
our desires and inclinations
um you know they could be shared with
other people
but they're not universal they're not
things that
everybody can say yes that that's
something that one ought to
to pursue went on to make an end and
then we have objective ends
which apply for any rational being now
notice any rational being
and i would actually add any rational
being who's actually acting in a
rational way and not sort of subverting
the rationality that they have so all
that said now
let's think about some examples some
examples that kant himself
doesn't cover so i think one of the best
ways to
think about this is by
contrast to another moral theory which
we call utilitarianism
one of the things that utilitarianism
would say is okay
is to distribute harms
or risks or losses or even frustrations
to a small group of people or even just
to one person if that's for the benefit
of the larger community
would that be permissible for somebody
like hunt
would this categorical imperative
say that that could be morally uh
justified
the answer is no why
well unless you're actually bringing
them into this very process
and making them you know aware of
everything that could happen and
allowing them to say yes or no to it
so it could be a voluntary choice of
their own
which usually isn't the case for these
sorts of things
you would be treating that person as a
mere means
let's take a fairly extreme example
let's say
for the sake of entertainment we
institute death matches between
uh convicted prisoners convicted
murderers let's say
um khan would say you can't do that sort
of thing
you you can do it but it would be
immoral to do it
because you would be treating those
people as means
uh for an end of entertainment of other
people and it wouldn't matter how many
other people you entertain it wouldn't
matter whether it's 100
or you know 100 000 or 100 million it
would still be wrong to do it
and the same thing would go if you think
about environmental
costs and benefits
or you know if you apply this to
economic dislocations you know when you
when you put
a lot of people at risk or deprive them
of their
their livelihood or their dignity
uh because it benefits the economy i
think from a conscient perspective that
would actually be something
wrong it would actually be something
immoral
because you would be treating those
people once again as
mere means to the end of greater
economic efficiency larger profit
or something like that even if you could
get them to sign
off on it i think that he would say
in that case they would be treating
themselves
as a mere means to some sort of and
unless they could actually recognize
that this is the thing that needs to be
done
morally it's the only good choice that
could be made
um they would be treating themselves as
a mere means to an end
and so the other people would be using
them if for example they were to take
financial inducements you know
if for example if we were to start a
lottery and say um
cancer will be distributed so that you
know only one person
gets uh cancer and when they do it
they'll get this payoff that'll you know
provide them with
five years of great life before they
they die of cancer
and nobody else will ever get cancer
again cat would say something like that
would not be a good thing to do
you know the person would be in effect
trading being used as a means
for the benefit of other people for
you know financial gain which would be
a subjective end of theirs but really
wouldn't be
an objective end but let's go on now
what about
some other cases kat says
not that it's generally wrong to lie to
people but then it's it's always wrong
to lie to people
he's very stringent when it comes to
that well why
think about what's going on when you
actually lie to a person
are you depriving them of anything
well when do you lie to somebody let's
let's take some actual cases
imagine you're a salesperson and you
have an inferior product
and you need to move that product
because if you don't
then you're not going to make any money
or perhaps even you'll lose your job
you'll be threatened with
something or another
so you lie to the person and you tell
them that this product that you're
selling is actually as good as or even
better
than the competitors products you're
treating that person then
as a means a means to whatever it is
that you're trying to attain by selling
that product whether it's you know
security whether it's a
financial gain whether it's the things
you get to buy with the money
whether it's self you know a sense of
self-esteem on your part
you would still be treating that person
as a mirror means to an end you'd be
depriving them of a good the good of
truth
you'd also be depriving them of the
capacity to make an informed choice
you would be interfering with their
capacity to set ends for themselves you
would not be treating them
as a genuinely free rational being you
would not be respecting humanity in them
what about some other examples what if
what if you could lie to one person
and that would help a lot of other
people well that would be similar to
the case of distributing harms in such a
way that only a few people got harms and
the rest of the people
were benefited or at least evaded the
harms
again you would be using those you would
be using the person to whom you're lying
you would be using them as a means to
say the happiness
or the welfare or
the further development pick whatever
you like of those other people
you know could we imagine situations
like that i think we can
you know think about how we might
conceal
things when we're asked about them from
a
family member who tends to fly off the
handle and make family
meetings uh unpleasant
as a result now i'm not myself a
conscience i would actually say in that
case yeah lie to them
and keep the peace because by behaving
like like you know
a fool in those cases they have in
some way deprived themselves of an
expectation
of being told the truth but kant would
say
no you actually if you're asked you know
point blank
you know is so and so doing this
and that's some scandalous thing that
will get this person on a tirade
can would actually say you actually do
have to tell the truth in that case
even though it's going to lead to to
worse consequences
for everybody else because otherwise
again
you're treating that person who you're
lying to
as a mere means to the happiness or or
harmony within the the group of the
other people
um let's take another case another
fairly cut and dry
case think about stealing um
now why do people steal let's take sort
of typical cases
as a matter of fact i'll actually use
one from my own childhood um
i remember shoplifting when i was a kid
and it was you know
fairly small stuff it was candy and we
were at the kickapoo store
and we almost got caught because we were
really stupid in the way we were doing
it
and the clerk was you know clearly
eyeing us up and we were scared we were
going to get caught by the cops
anyway why did we why did we do it well
i think the other kids did it basically
just because they like breaking the
rules
and because they've gotten away with it
before and because they like candy and i
shared that liking with them i liked
candy too
and i didn't like paying for candy
because back then you know we didn't
have a lot of money
candy was expensive we actually had to
walk about a mile and a half
through the meadows to get to this store
too by the way because we lived way out
in the country
so the other reason that i had
was i wanted to these were older boys
and they were you know kind of trouble
makers
and i was friends with them and i wanted
to fit in
so the question is
who's being used in this and this is a
case where
there's multiple uses going on so to
begin with i'm using the clerk
or perhaps the you know the store itself
which which is a you know
a company of people i'm using them
as a mere means to these aims that i
have
of getting candy on the cheaper for free
and impressing my friends and fitting in
you know whatever psychological needs
that i have
i'm treating those people as lower
as of less value than my friends who i
want to fit in with and
and myself and my own desires
now am i treating myself badly as a
result as well and this is something
that could apply to
some of these other cases too am i
treating the humanity in myself
in a way that makes it into a mere means
to certain ends i think yes
if my life is fundamentally centered
around candy and the consumption of
candy that's a flawed life
from a conscience perspective even for a
child
what i ought to be doing is developing
and
i want to be gaining i got to be
progressing as a moral being and instead
i'm actually setting myself behind
by um
doing something that's that's
establishing a bad habit doing something
that that
um brings culpability upon myself
particularly you know given the fact
that i'm doing this
with other uh other people
um
that reinforces it so i i am in fact
treating humanity within myself
as a mere means to something you know
getting candy
or the respect of other people it's kind
of ironic because
if they really respected me according to
kant what they would respect is my
capacity to
to do the right thing they wouldn't be
coercing me
or seducing me into doing the wrong
thing and and likewise for me i wouldn't
be doing that with
with them as well um
now what about other cases of stealing
this is where it starts to get kind of
interesting and kind of sticky
let's take the classic case of the
father who steals bread
because he has no livelihood his
livelihood has been eliminated and he
has to feed his children
is his act of stealing wrong
he is certainly
breaking the law
he's doing something that is to the
benefit of his children
as a matter of fact somebody like thomas
aquinas and considering this says
you know that's probably not even
properly described as stealing it's
proper
it's better described as doing what you
have to do to feed
people who you're responsible for kant
does not seem to go along with this sort
of thing
now does he go does he does he do this
because i would be treating humanity
in the baker as a mere means to an
end um
i suppose so this is one of those cases
where again
i would i would diverge from kant so
would thomas aquinas
uh presumably so would aristotle and so
would
the utilitarians and i would be inclined
to say
well what about the humanity in my my
children if i don't
actually go and get that bread
and i'm the only person who can do it
and the only way in which i can do it
the only way in which i can
actually keep them alive is by doing
this am
i not treating them as
something like a means to my own moral
rectitude
this is a puzzling case and and again i
am not entirely
aligned with kant on this this sort of
thing
um let's shift now to something else um
which might be less controversial
relationships
think about what goes on in
relationships do people use each other
yeah we know that they do because i mean
aristotle and discussing the the
different kinds of friendship which i
i'm going to produce another video on
some other time tells us hey some
friendships are
you know in terms of the person
themselves and their value and their
dignity and some are just in terms of
use
and we do experience a lot of
relationships in which we do
we do see people use each other or we
feel used
or we allow ourselves to be used count
would say in that case
what we're doing is actually wrong
so if two people marry and
um let's take the sort of typical trophy
bride
scenario the trophy bride is marrying
uh and they'll say well it's because i
love this guy but you look at him you're
like oh
no this guy is thoroughly repulsive
physically and morally and you know as a
person
uh there's no way that you're actually
in love with him you know you could be
in love with this guy over here
this guy over here but not this one he
just happens to be filthy rich
so she's using him for money she's
getting married to him she's making an
agreement with him
to what to allow access to to
her sexually to be sort of arm candy and
this could work the other way around too
it could be you know
a very rich but kind of repugnant woman
and some some boy toy too who's going
along for money
both people are using each other in that
case and some people would look at that
and say
nothing wrong with that so long as
they're okay with the terms of the
contract
perfectly fine for them they're
exercising their autonomy
kant would say well that's not really
autonomy
in the right sense that's following
purely subjective ends
deciding for yourself money is the
center of the universe but that's not
really being a rational being
and that's not respecting all the other
things in yourself
besides whatever it is that you're using
to make some money
there's more to you kant would say to to
a person in these cases
there's more to you than just a money
maker
you are worth more than that you're
worth more than any amount of
of dollars or bonds or stocks or
property or pick whatever you like
opportunities likewise kant would say to
the
uh to the uh the person who's you know
marrying the other person and getting
them into their relationship
by virtue of the fact that they have all
this money
um just so they can they can sleep with
them
who perhaps even just acquired all that
money so they can they can sleep with
people
he would say they are using the other
person clearly
and they're allowing themselves to be
used to
you know if you get into a relationship
with another person
and that other person is just using you
for money
you're they're doing something wrong to
you but you're allowing it to be done
to you by maintaining that relationship
by choosing that
by doing it over and over and over again
you're actually treating yourself as a
means to whatever it is that you're
getting out of that that situation it
could be
physical pleasure it could be prestige
it could be
self-satisfaction it could be a variety
of things but whatever it is
it's not going to be some sort of
objective end that everybody could look
at and say
that's the right thing to do that is
something that's really worth it
because people clearly look at and they
say what is wrong here
so what about other relationships
relationships are very hard
aren't they are there are there cases
where we do use each other
in relationships i think so
here's where we get to a very important
point remember i said earlier
you can treat a person as a means if
you're
also genuinely treating them as an
end at the same time i think that many
relationships and in particular
many marriages are cases
in which somebody's being used as a
means some of the time
but because they're also being furthered
they're being treated as an
end they're being they're being allowed
to develop to choose to to
engage in decision making together
at least that's the way a good marriage
is that's the way a true partnership
works
when you have that then you can have the
development of genuine intimacy
count doesn't talk much about that but i
think that you could actually fit that
into this framework
now what about something that would
threaten that cheating
adultery breaking one's one's uh
commitments to another person to to
remain faithful
i talked about this one before in the
video where i talked about the first
formulation of the categorical
imperative
what about in the second one let's say
i'm married to somebody
and i find somebody else that i think is
attractive and i go
and sleep with her
now i'm probably just treating that
person as a means means towards sexual
satisfaction right because i'm already
in a marriage
i'm not going to marry that person i'm
just you know engaging in sex
but i'm also treating that person who
i'm married to
in a way that is below the way that they
ought to be treated i'm treating them as
a means
i'm not treating them as an end because
how do i know that
well you know if i actually treated them
as an end one of the things that they
want is me not to go and screw somebody
else right
so if i were to actually respect the
the desires the capacity to set
goals the capacity to say this matters
to me
of the other person with whom i'm in a
committed relationship you know
it's committed right i would have to
stay faithful to them
would i also be treating myself as a
means to an end by
by breaking that that commitment
i think so i'd be treating myself as a
moral being
that's humanity as a mere means to
getting
getting some sexual gratification
so that would not be a moral act
let's think about another one actually
too where a person is being treated both
as a means
and as an end this is what i use in my
classes all the time when i discuss this
material
education itself when i walk in the
classroom
i'm there because i'm getting paid and
i probably would not be there
for at least most of the classes that i
teach i might volunteer to teach some
but i probably wouldn't be there for
most of them unless i was getting paid
so
i mean those students are in a certain
respect of means to an end as a matter
of fact when i teach
certain classes i might be paid per
student
it might matter the head count so each
person is worth this amount of money to
me
now if i were only to focus on that
um i would be treating them as just a
means to an end wouldn't i
if i were just to engage in a
transaction i'm going to give you this
intellectual content
and you're going to give me some money
back
and and that's all there is to it
then i would be i would be violating
this
there are other ways in which i could do
that as an educator as well
if i'm only getting up in front of these
students so i can have power over them
for example
i've known some pedagogues like that if
i'm doing it
just so i can be the as they say the
sage on the stage the big player
up in front of everybody else telling
them how it is and what they ought to
think
essentially demanding that they be my
audience
again i would be treating them as as a
means a means to something else a
different type of
subjective end that i have in this case
power
or authority or gratification rather
than merely
money what would i be doing as an
educator
how would i be able to treat them
as an end as somebody who actually gets
to make decisions
who has value who has human dignity
who can develop well i'd better actually
be teaching them some learning had
better be taking place and i had better
if i'm a real educator
be devoting quite a bit of thought to
how my students
do in fact learn and what this student
over here needs and what this student
over here needs
this would actually go down to the level
of curriculum design
i would go so far as to say this if
today
i am teaching college classes and
the only assignments that i have over
the course of the semester are two or
three papers over the course of the
semester and i'm not giving
feedback on those papers in a draft
process or something like that
i'm violating khan's categorical
imperative i would say because all i'm
doing then
is getting to study what i want to study
and using my
students is basically you know a way to
keep myself employed i'm not actually
teaching them the way that i could be
the way that i ought to be if i'm
teaching my students
in a 16 week class there would better be
weekly assignments at the very least and
i'd better
get those graded and get them feedback
so that these students can actually get
themselves if they go off course they
can get themselves back on course so
learning can really take place
then i would actually be treating them
as an end this is kind of interesting
because you know what it points out
is that maybe you know what it counts to
treat somebody as an end
gets more stringent as we learn more
about what's what's required
that leads us to another good good
example what about parenting
think about parents you look at them
and you can tell that they're just using
their children
as sort of little images of themselves
they are not concerned with what's
really good for the child
even though they've managed to convince
themselves that whatever it is that
they're doing is really good for the
child
they want the child to go and be in this
club or play this sport
or do this thing or get this grade point
level because that's what would look
good
on them it would reflect good on them
and then they would feel like they're a
good parent
ironically by doing that they're
actually not a good parent certainly
not in any sort of conscience sense
they're they're actually violating the
categorical imperative
they are treating their children as mere
means to an end
what is required for for a parent a real
parent
has to care about their children
in such a way that they tend to promote
the development of their children
as human beings that's to treat them as
an end
it doesn't mean giving in to them out of
everything doesn't mean being friends
with your kids
it doesn't mean saying whatever you
choose little junior
is a-okay because you know some of the
subjective ends that kids have are crazy
stuff that's not good for them right i
mean that's part of the process
of growing up is trying to do
trying to get away with some crazy stuff
and then you know
learning by experience that it's not a
good idea hopefully by watching some
other poor bastards
you know bad experience not having to
undergo it yourself but
somewhere along the line if the parents
are not treating the child
as an end and treating the child as an
end i think
is going to require more and more and
more as the child gets gets older
there will be a lot more things when the
child is young where the parent
can be you know much more authoritative
this is difficult to this is not easy
stuff to nail
down but this is really worth thinking
about in terms of khan's categorical
imperative
formulation too because it has to do
with this this central conception
of whether you are treating a person as
a mere means it's just an object
to satisfy your own or somebody else's
desires
even if it does satisfy some of their
own desires or whether you're treating
them
as an equal whether you're treating them
as somebody
who has equal dignity with you even
though they may not have the same power
position
as having the same value as you
you know a parent who punishes if they
really
can say and really mean it this is this
is hurting me
more than it's going to hurt you i think
in that case the parent would not just
be treating the child as a means but
be treating the child as an end if the
parent is punishing the kid
and enjoying the punishment
and they're punishing the kid because
they like doing that they're treating
that kid as a means
if the parent is punishing the kid so
that the kid stays out of trouble so
that the parent doesn't look bad
in the eyes of their peers again they're
treating them as a means they're not
treating them as an end and kids
perceive this
kids can can see through this sort of
thing because kant is on to something
really vital here
let's think about one other example can
you
sell yourself in the sense of engaging
in degrading behavior
um humiliating behavior for
the you know financial gain would that
be
allowable clearly not kant would say in
that case you're treating humanity in
yourself
as a mere means to financial gain if you
were to do that for other reasons to fit
in
allowing other people to say line up and
and uh
humiliate you and you put up with it
just because you want to
fit in first off you're not really
fitting in but again you would be
treating
humanity in yourself as a mere means
not as an end and you'd be allowing
other people to treat that that humanity
in yourself as a mere means as well
could you do things like this in other
respects
um prostitution i think khan would say
prostitution would be an example of this
where you allow somebody to use you for
financial gain and again that would be
allowing somebody
to use your humanity as a mere means and
thereby treating yourself
as a mere means in in the process even
if you're making good money out of it
even if you choose your clients i think
kant would say
in this case it would not be moral
that's probably a good place to to leave
off we've covered a lot of examples
hopefully by now this somewhat abstract
formulation has attained some
some consistency and some some you know
actual
flesh for you and now you have a much
better understanding of how to apply
kant's categorical imperative second
formulation